what's happening reject nation greg and
john
here right now it is 12 45 in the
morning and we are going to watch
falcon in the winter soldier episode 3.
i just got back from the airport from
being away for a week two hours ago
thanks john for picking me up no problem
buddy
but hey we're back in a video together
john
it's the end of an era end of an era
here i mean i paid and paid you have
major compliments in my suicide squad
video oh
but but
you've come a long way since your uh i i
screamed
sandwich what was that movie oh the ice
there was some
movie there shouts out to megan friels
johnston i feel bad about that i i
shot so many takes shots shot
for hours trying to say the right thing
john's early days are
trying to do solo videos and then see
where you are now i'm like bam
johnny i learned from the best take it
away no no no you're your own man you do
your own thing and you have your own
style and flavor
take it away do the intros oh guys
now now i'm gonna be so natural
this is reaction highlights here on
youtube we can only show about 10-ish
minutes of footage so if you want to
watch the full show along with us sync
up with the time code that's available
over at our patreon along with a whole
bunch of other
shows and a couple movies as well
there's a whole bunch of images here
that's flashing up come watch some cool
tv with us
big thanks to eric at nerd chronic for
editing this
for editing a bunch of our recent huge
videos always doing a great job and
holding it down he does
editing for the movie trivia showdown
iman snow a bunch of other people you
watch and uh yeah
like subscribe for the next video click
that notification balance
i'm running out of the steam let's jump
into this video
[Music]
the global repatriation council knows
that for many
it wasn't that easy helping you get back
to the way things were
the flag smashers want to smash all
those flags
reset restore rebuild
reduce reuse recycle
my name is john walker
oh do you know who i
am
yes i do and i don't care
it's a waste of time man i was captain
of the football team
meanwhile on the other side of germany
because you're an avenger you know how
he feels about that [ __ ] it's not like
you two are known for frolicking in the
sun together he was obsessed with high
trial
we have a history together trust me what
a great way to recap
yes like in case you guys forgot wait a
minute bucky's in other movies
bucky is he's war machine
those days are over i just wanted to see
how the new you
reacts to the old words
he didn't say homecoming someone
recreated the super soldiers here
can i get can i get some hmm he's like a
hannibal lecter position
yeah what are you talking about you want
to break them
[Music]
he is crazy but he still has a code yeah
and i've been on the wrong side of that
code bucking so have you
look let me just walk you through a
hypothetical this same garage where
bucky was held in civil war i don't know
house of m
and if two prisoners start fighting then
the protocol says
oh dang
someone could use the chaos at their
advantage
this is a great hypothetical where are
we man
[Laughter]
i do like that trope i did not see that
coming
you broke the law and you stuck your
neck out from me this is the exact same
i really think i'm in value shut up
okay zemo
where do we start this plan gone got a
shirt
enemy of mine enemy
oh he's got his mask right there why
don't you tell us about where we're
going
i was just fascinated by this i don't
know what to call it but
who is nakajima
don't well he's found a trigger word
yeah he's already getting in his head i
told him about trouble man he wrote in
that book
what'd you think you didn't like it i
liked it
it is a masterpiece james completed
captures the african-american experience
he's out of line but he's right
[Laughter]
let's see if there's one mutant hint
magifor just what
[ __ ] says a lot of atmosphere
yeah it's gonna become a john wick fight
in a minute
cyberpunk 2077
audi's back to working with marvel
yeah there is like a cyberpunk like
blade runner
vibe to it yeah and then bucky gets to
be johnny silver arm
it all works out
power broker is watching
we have business to do with selby
oh is that uh sharon
ew what's the usual
wow indy indiana jones
i would never
you what if you're undercover i love
these i'm smiling tiger
this is how i express my joy
no no no snakes
are over my biggest fears
really embody this role oh
let's get this on tape
oh man
you good
it could be worse you could be doing
that to good people
that's true everyone in here is up to
something
nefarious you wouldn't be here
if you you're up to good you're smaller
than i'd heard
smiling tiger
aye what's the offer tell us what you
know about the super soldier serum
the power broker had him working on the
serum but
things didn't go as planned is nagel
still in madrid
before you get all cute don't think you
can find naked without me
smiling tiger here it's not a good time
answer it on speaker
oh no you forgot to turn off your phone
we need to talk about the situation it's
been dropping me nuts what situation
sarah say it
the damn boat watch your tone okay i'll
let you slide at the bank
yeah laundered so much money
they'll come around
cash what did i tell you about the
cheerios i don't have confidence
sam i'm sorry let me call you back no
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh it is like john wayne yeah just like
banners
you just get to the continental come on
oh there's no safety point here
yeah they don't get an hour
seem to have a guardian angel so this is
too perfect
there she is drop it zemo
someone recreated the super soju serum
so what are you doing here
i stole steve's shield i also took the
wings for your ass so that you could
save his ass from his ass
sharon we need your help
are they not being chased anymore
it's just two people yeah i guess they
were just like we're gonna call off the
search
slight convenience yeah it's like yes
it seemed like everyone in the city was
gonna
much better no have we got an anthony
maggie marvel body shot
dude where are those abs turn around
by the way how is the new cap don't get
me started before you were his pet
psychopath you were
mr america cat's best friend wow
wow she's very redefined huh yeah
we need your help sharon i can get your
name clear
i'm just looks like she's leading a
pretty good life
for being on the run i mean they cleared
the bionic staring machine
and he killed almost everybody he's met
i heard that i don't trust charity
you help us out and i'll get your name
clear
[Music]
that's a great reaction try to stay out
of trouble
i'll see what i can find trouble
i really love the they
they really have redefined zemo in a lot
of ways oh yeah
i really love it fully breathe as a
human character yeah
i thought he was just some like family
man with a science background
and that's civil war like that's how
they portrayed him in here he's like
oh he's like a criminal underworld guy i
just got tasted
he's got connects he knows everyone i've
seen civil war a few times that's how
they portrayed him yeah just like
yeah i lost my family but i you know
then i kind of turned it
i'll keep an eye out when you guys talk
to [ __ ] but hurry we're on borrowed
time
oh i love action scenes at the docks
the docks
it's a false you're smart
who are you what do you want guys we
have company
one day that line's going to be a
positive thing an action move
oh
yeah god that there's sound effects
yeah every bounty hunter in the city
yo get those wonders boy
ah okay okay
oh did that homeboy seems to be raining
[Laughter]
i was able to isolate the necessary
compounds in his blood
i was a god oh you killed batman
i free your mother
[Laughter]
before i was able to complete my work
then when i returned
it was five years later
yo sharon is holding this whole thing
this whole what do you guys should be
out here with
dude she's great with a knife
guys we're seriously out of time here
oh what did you do
i'm kind of wondering if that's what's
going to happen with one of them you
never know
at this point i'm going to throw
anything and everything out
i thought we were going to go left you
went the wrong way
[Applause]
oh here it goes
this dude's a gamer
what the hell he's agile what the hell
oh javelin's style supercharged
if you try that [ __ ] again
of course you would come back to the
states with us i told you i can't
just get me that part and you promise me
thanks for everything sherry carter spin
off in the works oh here we go you're
not going to move your seat up
no
get it not gonna make it easy on old sam
civil wars okay and this one's sharing
with the they've
met share okay
[Music]
like we don't have to do this right now
yes we do
do you want morn huh grieve a little bit
not talk about your feelings
[Laughter]
maybe you get to be a teacher after all
this is over right
is he gonna die he's gonna die i
just started getting charmed
you seriously think sam and bucky would
have broken a guy like timo out of
prison that's exactly what i think they
did they were just as desperate for
leaves as we were
come on man which is why you and i are
just going to run with this one
we get the job done do you really think
they're going to sweat us on the howl
yes protocols what happened with captain
america
[Laughter]
of course maybe i shouldn't have put it
in a museum maybe i should have
destroyed it
no it belongs in a museum
it ain't gonna be walker so before you
go and destroy it i'm gonna take it from
myself
is he declaring he's gonna step up and
be the new cat
that's a challenge right there at least
i for one am looking forward to coming
face to face with
carly where's nick we're changing the
course
i love i love what they're doing with
you it just it just seems like
so much of this history is not in some
war or at least i
that completely has left my brain in it
there's
i just remembered him being like yeah
family man who was hurt
and then he had science background and
then he wanted revenge for what happened
to kobe
oh so he was the one who came out of the
building in that yeah crazy shot
in the first episode yeah yeah now
go home
there's still people in there this is
the only language these people
understand
oh no no now you're just
you're going off the deep end taking it
too
far
jason buck
jason barnes that's even better
yo what it do
no way all right good
[ __ ] guys yeah good [ __ ] nice looking
good time
really quick really quick i think
adorama lager girl is in civil war
i don't know the character's name survey
says
10 minutes later yes florence kasumba
and
he's the one who tells black widow move
or i'll make you move something like
that or you will be moved that's the
line
right there oh that's exciting
everything from civil war all
coming back around absolutely
full circle john can't leave a single
stone unturned in terms of auxiliary
characters who we've seen once or twice
in the past
but i mean that's super exciting and
obviously
yeah the second you break zemo out all
the people who have a bone to pick with
him
are gonna come running it's not just the
people you're disturbing here in madrid
it had that pulsating sort of espionage
movie flavor
like you know the captain america movies
started to incorporate especially as of
winter soldier and civil war but
stretched out in a way that felt even
more like a bond movie
meets hannibal lecter or something like
that you know the classic
you know we gotta go break out the enemy
of my enemy to form an unlikely alliance
and yeah like you said
like getting to see zemo just strut out
his
full personality from a position of you
know comfort and power because he knows
what his leverage is
like it's making for a really fun
dynamic
and especially as a means of mixing
things up for sam and bucky but also
giving
them a common enemy probably to unite
over as the series goes along you know
that seems pretty smart
weirdly the movie reference that i was
most getting from this was
specifically mission impossible fallout
ah i don't remember the name of the
villain and who's in rogue nation and
fallout but getting that genius level
villain
and you have to team up with them and
you're in these european countries
yeah like you bond is an act of
reference and so is i think mission
impossible that was that was a little
bit more of the vibes i got here i felt
a lot of inspirational stuff
that they were pulling from this like
yes i think a lot of people
are gonna go that's like john wick you
know all that stuff in madrid
the sharon carter fight scenes
especially have a look
of that like brutal using whatever
weapons you got around you
type of eye good thing you're at one of
our favorite action set pieces
the docs yes classic gets those
dark crates best place to have action
scenes instant production value
they're all over the place hallways and
are the best place to have bathrooms
nowadays it's to the point where i just
assume that only nefarious deeds go
down at a dock where there are lots of
shipping rights yeah
does like honest work ever happen amidst
shipping crates
you see a sailor come on by
i got another haul of vcr but my my big
takeaway
uh it was in in fact baron's kind of
just the rewriting of the characters
right down to evilly vancamp as sharon
carter i have a couple of nitpicks if
i'm being honest here you know
and then my weekly wage on it it made me
go i gotta
i gotta bring up my nitpicks more
because
bringing up the nitpicks are fun because
honestly if i were to rate this episode
i'd say like a 99
would be my rating okay but that one
percent but if i give some nitpicks
those are the comments right there yes
that's the engagement i hate that i hate
this
knowledge you didn't just let him go
yeah i gotta pick it apart a little bit
all right all right air your hatred for
the show
i feel like with zemo it's it's really
interesting to me how
uh how many times have you seen civil
war just like one time
seemed to pro two probably solid tough i
am going off of memory so where i i must
have seen that movie at
minimum and as much as a lot of you guys
i'm sure a lot of you guys probably just
go to the airport battle
but the whole move from beginning to end
i've seen it less than 10 times
um not not a whole lot maybe this is a
more accurate portrayal of how zemo is
in the comics i imagine so however
when it comes to like who he was in the
movie
like he just seemed like the family guy
uh
you're a family man
who had a family but he had like a
science background and then
uh once sokovia age of ultron it's
moments happened
he started taking a dark turn and
started coming up with mastermind paths
they seem like a dude who came from a
like he was a father
means yeah and then here is like luxury
and criminal underworld yeah and he's
got the taste
for all the winery but also all that
yeah underworld living
he's got to have that artistic merit of
like a fanciful criminal
you know i love it though like i think
who uh daniel brawl
i i think he's such a great actor yeah i
think my first introduction to him was
in glorious bastards which did
have a uh christophe waltz who was like
the go-to great
classic and uh daniel bruhl was was
i didn't think he was doing a christophe
waltz but this version of zemo
felt a little bit more akin to that but
i liked him like man on the street
involved in the action you don't know
where his allegiances
really lie here when he shoots dr nagel
like oh there it is he's got the mask
now he's no longer playing team with
them he's doing his own thing and then
he pulls back around with the car i'm
like i
don't know which direction dude full
control i don't know which direction you
lie
yeah here's what i'll say or before i
give my nitpick about emily van camp
much prefer this version of her over the
other ones
that we got in winter soldier in civil
war absolutely
way prefer her she seems like an actual
character here
yeah less so your fantasy of a you know
spy operative who can blend in as a
charming woman or whatever
and also with the civil war kiss that
she has with steve which has
been very much like criticized or made
fun of
yeah so to have her show up here
actually you know i might take my
nitpick back ooh god damn it greg you're
just like everything don't change
not before you even leave all right my
mind went
way i was i was gonna say that i feel
like the
sort of reinvention they've done with
zemo in the mcu
weirdly feels very natural it fits
great and i love it whereas with emily
van camp
i kind of felt the writer's room
you know what i mean i kind of felt like
we need to make sure more interesting
that's not a bad thing
you know no that's what i mean when i
say a niffic it's a nitpick only because
i could feel
kind of the the note yeah i mean she's
so
good at playing it but but go on oh i
was i mean i was gonna say was
however like the direction they took it
and why she's behaving that way and why
she is the way she is
actually makes perfect sense yeah so
that just might be my own little
personal projection i was putting on the
character
in the moment yeah but it's also an
instance where you do have
two characters who again are
experiencing the benefit of these series
which is oh we can actually let them
be breathing characters and not just
plot points to make way for the main
characters
so yeah i feel like you have two big
changes and and that contrast
kind of comes out of there and yeah it's
very natural to assume that zemo even
though we didn't see all this
with the position he's been in and just
the things he knows from all these
experiences you know you can see him
developing this sort of cynical
above it all sort of confidence yes you
know all right okay i got it i got an id
pick all right let's do it all right
okay no this is like a real nitpick
a lot of people do theories like nah i
came back home
one just provide a couple of nitpicks
everyone's rights and nitpicks video but
the thing is when i give a nitpick i'm
immediately followed with
well here's why it's actually it works
you know okay
falcon uh anthony mackey with the cell
phone what is it shawarma tiger
with striped tiger smiling
to me i'm like ah amateur move but
here's the other part when you first
walked into madrid
the club it was loud right there's
bouncing
music you need to feel if your phone's
going off yeah to me i'm like
yeah that's that's a very human thing to
forget and i really liked how it
played into the scene that's the thing
about why that nitpick suddenly goes
away because i'm like well in a lifey
way
that actually really works because when
she said put it on speaker
yeah because they don't work it out it
just goes poorly i think that's what's
the saving grace is like it is a little
bit of a funky moment because you're
like oh yeah amateur however like set
your phone on vibrate but also it does
create a great moment of tension and one
of those things that plays on your
expectations of the form i think because
you're
then going okay he's gonna work his way
out of this somehow or he's to give her
enough codes
and the funny thing is in that scene
like the prompts he's giving her i was
like do you want to get caught
he's like tell me exactly what you're
talking about and i'm like she's gonna
say the boat or something
you know this is where i'm not sure if
it's a nitpick or natural criticism
falcon in this episode i really love
the scene on the plane when him and
bucky are talking about maybe i
shouldn't have given up the shield maybe
i should have just destroyed it entirely
and they're having the debate of so much
that the series has been about symbolism
and our association to what that symbol
is whether that be something
light or dark good or positive usually
based around
who embodies the symbol right that's
been a big part of the discussion so
having that conversation further examine
that thematic exploration i thought was
powerful
a lot of this though i did start kind of
feeling like
falcon specifically was a little bit of
a
joke in this episode he's a bit
sidelined because so much of this rides
on zemo's relation
to bucky yeah bruce that they can play
and then anthony mackie is sort of
relegated to being
a comedic relief because smiling tigers
kind of wacky
yeah smiling tiger the cell phone [ __ ]
trying to [ __ ] his way
was it was a little silly yeah and uh
then when they see the art gallery
photos going on google oh [ __ ] you know
like it didn't bother me that much it
did feel though that he was a little bit
undercut in this episode as opposed to
the previous two where i felt like oh
he's kind of just being funny he did
have his scenes though he didn't have a
certain moment
so back to the nitpick
[Laughter]
this is like a many layers of steepness
from the exception
you know how i was saying how i actually
really liked how the cell phone thing
played in to like a real-life moment of
oh when oh she wants to put it on
speaker like that
that's real and then the bounty thing
starts happening and then uh sharon
shows up shoots those two guys on the
bikes and then they just
stop to have a quick expositional
dialogue
no one's chasing them anymore that did
pull me out of the moment
of probably more into the information
being conveyed to me right now
yeah but we just saw them like trying to
run away and then they were being
haunted by everyone in this city what
seemed like everyone yeah but then they
all waited to show up at the docks the
next day apparently yeah we'll never
find them you know where they're
definitely going like how do they lose
that
i got a place is there something i
missed no
it's not a big deal because i really
like the sharing scene that followed
after that and when they're in the hotel
and the explanation of all that
i really enjoyed all that and i love the
reinvention of her character for the
most part so
yeah it's just that's
what it unethical it feels like sharon
got it yeah
yeah that's your filter that's a new
that's a difficult a great pick
but it feels like sharon got the lion's
share of the action that sam might have
had you know so maybe
the next episode oh that's a great call
you know it's like they spread it around
that way so maybe the next episode bucky
will take a back seat and then it'll be
the falcon show
and bucky will just be all comic relief
while sharing kicks asses
sam does the hard work i mean i think
you might have hit the nail on the head
there
was when they are interrogating uh dr
nagle
i can't remember if it was me or you
said it but one of us said
we both thought someone should be out
there helping shared fight
i think you said that yeah
feel like falcon should maybe be the one
in there i mean it's important for him
to get this info but at the same time it
seems like one of them could maybe help
her out
especially if he's got wings and like
needs like i don't know if he wants to
use all the tech because maybe they
could trace it or something but yeah
the extra hand on deck would be were his
wings destroyed in the last episode
i don't think the wings were just red
wing right but then he didn't keep
flying around
i wasn't sure if it was just like hey
for this part of the mission this is not
practical
you know yeah it's true regardless i'm
i'm happy to have them back
i hope we see more sharon carter i loved
a lot of what they did with her she was
very badass and i'm glad that emily
vancamp
she was a little more peggy yeah a
little more peggy
yeah man she can take care of herself
and everyone else
literally around me should i cut the
nitpicks
because that is my social experience
start a thing
starting with things my social
experience yeah dope tropes now we got
nitpicks
speaking of dopamine really i haven't
said anything that negative
no but we'll see that's the nitpicks it
was not that negative we'll see how it
goes
but i do i do love the dope trope of
we're gonna explain the plan
as the plan is happening with the whole
like zemo breaking out and it's like
yeah the second [ __ ] is done
explaining this zemo's just gonna walk
in the room
and uh it was it was choice it was well
executed oh i said it and
i really didn't see it coming out i
thought like falcon was going to come in
and be like no here's everything that
will go wrong
okay we're going to watch the we're
going to do it three months because i
thought that's
where we're going i wasn't seeing the
ghosts got to take the
coming out yeah i thought the episode
was going to be dedicated to breaking
him out
yeah well that's which would have been a
cool episode
come on that would have been a cool
episode here of it so absolutely i mean
you could have made a bottle episode out
of that
nitpick nitpick yeah that's the
interesting thing is
is i do appreciate to a degree that they
aren't wasting time with a lot of stuff
and like anything that seems like it
could be a problem
becomes a problem i think that's the
other thing these shows help to show you
is like well now that we're zooming in
this far we can zoom in even further and
explore even more characters
it's like with the carly character you
know i she had a different name
last name because what's carly's last
name
though oh wow good good good job
thanks man did you really remember that
yeah
yeah yeah and every time i've seen it i
don't know for whatever reason it really
stands out to me
thanks that was great which is adapted
from carl morgan now who is the
singular flag smasher character oh yes
that's
i don't know why my mind didn't go there
because it's it's
carly and i started thinking that i
carly my next
hi carly morgan i was i think that's
really cool i've ever seen his eye
i'm morgan oh now neither of us is going
to forget this name ever
no definitely not carl morgan
she is tracy morgan yeah so
carly mark morgenthau yeah it's a long
day it's a few hundred miles to come to
your vocation
just for that just for you like with her
character i think we've harped on this
point before of how this show's been
doing such a good job of exploring
the gray of all these situations right
down to zemo
yeah you're like no i i don't think zemo
would go all good
like no obviously not i'm just waiting
for the moment we're like always full on
villain again
even in the eyes of falcon and
winter soldier he's a full-on villain
i'm waiting for that moment
whereas carly they are like kind of this
robin hood characters of sorts this was
the most
sympathetic i felt the direction took
carly and the flags
carly and the flag smasher carly and the
flagstaff harlem the black smash
yeah man musical specials there's a
sing-along it's great
my point with that is even though when
they break down they're like there's
still people in there
you know not aquaman says that and uh
you know it's like
this is all the only language they know
i'm like well no that's the whole point
you're not supposed to be speaking that
language you know you're saying
your own even though i thought this
episode took the most sympathetic
approach with carly out of all the
episodes
this still ends it on the note with them
of
they're the bad ones but are they really
gonna be the baddies
you know what i mean are they really
gonna be bad well yeah i mean it
definitely pits carly in a position
where you know you've got the looming
threat of the power broker and the idea
that you know her having stolen this
serum is gonna mean something real nasty
for her and and yeah it's one of those
things where she has
questionable ethics when it comes to a
certain line
um and at the same time it also seems
like they've drawn her yes just as this
very genuine character who really
believes in and cares for the cause that
she's fighting for so i
have to imagine that yeah zemo is gonna
be your big mustache twirling comic book
villain
and carly i have to imagine will have a
greater more sympathetic outcome to some
extent even if it's tragic even if she
dies or something
this was definitely the most like we're
just gonna peer in on her as a character
not necessarily the action side of what
that means but just like you know what
are her concerns who are the people
close to her et cetera so we don't
actually see the power broker in this
episode i know he's just talked about
or maybe the power broker is one of
these characters maybe the power broker
is is florence kasumbo
yes that's been her all along that's
what they want to make
the dorm logic she was security for
black panther in uh civil war
yeah having her come back around oh what
a cool
call to do and talk about honoring the
there's
so much civil war references in here
it's mainly civil war out of out of the
mall i think
i think right down to the whole thing
with are you going to move your received
avenger
can you move no the whole thing with
moving your seat
up is so like that was that was so
like sometimes you do these nods in the
movies and shows
and if you're not paying close attention
you'd think it's just a regular joke
yeah sometimes it might just fly over
your head like oh yeah that's a nod
but that was such a nod was that the
moment when they're like maybe
down the road we should do a falcon
winter soldier show like this
civil war when that when that moment
happens you know dang
that was their chemistry test it could
be because that was a funny moment that
was a really funny moment
and a surprisingly unexpected one to
occur in the movie
that became a real mean moment so to
have it come
back here to do it so overtly like
remember are you gonna move your seat up
no i got the way they're cutting it like
it's such an in-your-face reference
yeah which as someone who loved that
scene i i personally really liked it i
could
see a nitpick though oh of being like
don't you think they could have
more subtly done it the answer is yes
i think the other answer is most would
probably
is especially if it's small enough that
it could float over somebody's head just
go for it
you know they sometimes gave falcon
lines in here
to re-clarify for the audience the
situation they were in
that we didn't really need like when um
what's her name salman selma
selby selby damn you're good with the
names today john
as always this was a distinct name so
it's soby
zoby got shot yeah they're going to pit
it on us
this is the literally most suspicious
looking scenario you could be in right
now
especially after that phone call with
other people witnessing it
their picks nitpicks the good nature of
nitpicks
zimmo zimzimo zebo zemo is
so wealthy who do you have before you so
are you so depressed you could have
bought people to get over your pop
people to replace your family
buy a new family my new family man
what gives i remember how wealthy you
were i thought you were just a working
man in sokovia
winter soldier programs make a winter
family program
make some family members you can store
on ice take on your dreams well there's
just more to him than meets the eye like
he
says he says yes
yes that was what i said
you she i should have had a pause for
you to insert that
it was important as important as a good
reference yes because zemo he says
like my work is not yet finished like
he's shutting down the winter soldier
programs and like in civil war when you
see
all the people when when uh tony bucky
cap
yep sometimes i might say something like
tony iron man and cat i'll show him like
wait no
there's the same person near my eye yeah
when they all show up and you see that
all the people in the
water tanks is like called merle shot uh
he
ended the program he seems to have a
real vendetta against it
so i don't know if it is specifically
when he's saying
my work is not yet finished if it's
about shutting the super soldier serum
down
i think he wants to get to the flag
smashers
wants to get to carly and work with her
i could
perhaps lead the flag smashers yeah i
mean in some way
that would be an interesting outcome
take take like the subject of so much
ire but then mix it with a new ideology
that would appeal to him or something
like that
because i think they're trying to build
up thaddeus ross in here i think they're
trying to build up the power broker
as like the big villain but he's not i
don't think he is i think it's going to
be thaddeus
ross unless thaddeus ross is the power
broker then
wow multitasker
task master multi-task
nitpicks can you imagine
that'd be crazy why not it's all general
roster
it would be like rush hour it would be
just like russia
and tom wilkins said he's doing it all
man he's [ __ ] doing wrong putting the
cobia cords in order and giving super
soldiers here
you know like sometimes you just don't
see that coming
international conspiracies are really
confusing
well john and i could do solo videos but
nothing is as
unfocused as when both of us are
together
anyway we've been talking for 28 minutes
and most people didn't make it this far
so we'll watch new rockstars video or
tomorrow yeah there's some cool stuff
what i really love too in terms of the
story they are telling was
dr nego like i started this i got
blipped away
i know the middle of my work came
like the world of the blip is is so it
affects us
it's so weird how far from home kind of
does it
wanda vision kind of does it
but this show rides so much off of
living in that post blip world yeah and
like with walker and uh
lamar yeah what's going on there exactly
well lamar speaks german and they're
both hunting uh the trail that sam and
bucky are on
losers yeah man they are the womp womp
team
they're just gonna follow bucky and
sam's progress all over the place and
be like damn they were already here well
i guess we gotta move on and follow
their trail
i am wondering how this is all going to
coalesce by the end though um
he's got zemo here you got power broker
it's like yes they're chasing the same
thing but the plot
of new captain america john walker
is such a its own plot its own can of
worms
as it is and i'm wondering how much of
that will factor into all this stuff
i mean it's going to factor in i'm just
wondering how much it will
smoothly come to a resolve or conclusion
how to resolve an ending note here with
with these characters there's always a
little bit of open-endedness with an mcu
property i know that
it's just for the story they are telling
in this
series which is presumably just one
season
will it have an ending button at all
because i feel like there's so much
there's so much happening there's a lot
happening yeah absolutely and
it's like there's the implications that
about sam's backstory with the boat and
all that i'm like
oh [ __ ] we had yeah little bit of an
update on that but she's gonna call back
next episode with your info on that yeah
i mean john walker i have to imagine
that that's gonna at least
escalate i could sort of see it becoming
this thing where they
end off the series with his you know
formation
being complete as whatever villainous
you know us agent or whatever entity
that is or sinister you know and if not
outright villainous but i have to
imagine
this is gonna be kind of an origin story
for that character or they'll just wrap
him up entirely but i don't know yeah
given what these series are here to do
i have to feel like he's gonna amount to
something i would hope especially if
they're bothering to bring in battle
star like other characters connected to
the john walker lore and all that stuff
that's the one thing about the trailers
that kind of does spoil something
if you've even seen the very first
trailer for the disney plus shows
like when it was the 32nd one of the
three you see falcon
and presumably now in his home in
louisiana throwing the shield around
yeah yeah yeah and so they must steal it
yeah that's what i mean i'm like there's
a lot going on right here
unless it's a flashback because part of
john walker's journey
what i'm being reminded of is a little
bit of emil blonsky
of a soldier dedicated to his job
trying to do the best he could possibly
do
and he's getting desperate and when you
get desperate you start making
bad decisions and who
was guiding emil blonsky in the mcu
oh thunderbolt that's right
guys oh look out now finally got it
extend that olive branch to universal
every time there's a little bit of a
such a marvel fan thing to do anytime
there's a little bit of a reference to
the incredible hulk they're like they're
finally acknowledging
that there's a tiny bastard a child of
the fc
the littlest thing they're finally you
know they said
harlem those two white giants
fought all right guys well
i don't know good episode we got some
nitpicks yeah we're gonna
do we've got nitpicks what are you gonna
do overshadow the whole review
and yeah the action was great terrific
action
i will say i thought by this point we
would kind of be all like full force
bucky and sam in their relationship and
this seemed to not really be that much
about it other than that one scene on
the plane
yeah and the not moving the seat up but
otherwise yeah but everything else was
like the guest stars stole the show yeah
which i mean it seems like maybe that's
part of what they're
doing thematically is is maybe they're
going to parcel bucky and sam out a
little
further now while they you know it's
like last episode we zoomed in on john
walker this episode we
zoomed in mostly on carly and then just
developed
sharon and zlatan further so yeah i
wonder if
the next one will get back to kind of
the personal dynamic between sam and
bucky
or if we're gonna just explore some more
characters sure
sure yeah yes
capital capital my good man
capital nitpick there
it's mint it's gonna be forever this is
gonna be
a good assembly problem it's gonna take
20 minutes i hope eric cuts down the
highlights into five minutes so this
video is not an hour and a half
all the videos need to be that long for
me to actually get the monetize maybe
all right guys thanks for being here
subscribe
close this out john you have to do guys
what did you think of this episode hit
us with your thoughts down below
your theories tell us what we're wrong
about enlighten us
on stuff remember to like subscribe and
click that notification bell
thanks to anyone and everyone who's
checked us out on patreon and we'll
we'll see you tomorrow as well as next
week and every day
[Music]
cheers